A new observation of the bending of distant starlight
by gravity has allowed researchers
to weigh a white dwarf star,
virtually impossible before now for an isolated star.
One of the key predictions of Einstein’s
general theory of relativity
is that the curvature of space near a massive body,
such as a star,
causes a ray of light passing near it
to be deflected by twice the amount
that would be expected.
So when a star passes between us
and a more distant star,
we should see the distant star shift position or --
in the case of perfect
alignment --
become distorted into a perfectly
circular ring of light –
a so-called “Einstein
ring.”
One of the first convincing proofs
of general relativity
came in 1919 during an eclipse of the sun
when astronomers saw its gravity
shift the position of stars
close to its edge.
In recent decades,
astronomers have seen the gravity of galaxies
produce Einstein rings of more distant galaxies,
and stars briefly brighten the image of other stars
in a process known as gravitational microlensing,
but detecting a position shift caused by a star
other than the sun has been too small to discern.
Seeing such a shift would be very useful to
astronomers
because it would provide a way to
to directly measure the mass of the intervening star,
something that is very hard to do unless
a star is in a binary pair
when their orbits reveal their mass.
Recently, researchers realized
that the keen eyesight of the
Hubble Space Telescope might
be able to spot such movement
so went looking for stars
that might soon be in alignment.
They found that the nearby white dwarf Stein 2051 B
was set to pass nearly in front of
another star in March of 2014.
They then used Hubble to measure tiny shifts
in the apparent position of the background
star as Stein 2051 B passed by.
The researchers’ measurements
put the white dwarf star’s mass
to be about 0.675 solar masses.
As well as demonstrating the power
of this new technique,
the work also solved an enigma
surrounding Stein 2051 B.
An earlier mass estimate had made it
substantially lighter, too light for a white dwarf
of that type, casting doubt on the theory
of how such burnt-out stellar remnants form.
But the new measurement puts Stein 2051 B’s
mass exactly where it should be.
With this one measurement,
the researchers have confirmed Einstein’s prediction,
demonstrated a valuable new technique,
and reinforced the theory of stellar evolution.
That's a good day’s work.